alright man you know coming to you live
from that new studio here in Los Angeles
California the studio formerly known as
the fighter in the kids studio I'm
coming for everything I got that guests
at a year and I got now I got that
studio and what's next you don't want to
give me a title belt y'all don't want to
give me a coffee mug for winning that
goty harm fighter in the kid well guess
what
daddy's bout to take it all let's go oh
[Music]
yeah oh yeah
that's him baby
[Music]
hit that riff boy marry riff muss
[Music]
hire a volunteer but was found in this
mountain is that Stevie starlight you
and me baby nation nation
[Music]
come on this is it baby come on guys get
up too late to come home
I slept some way
[Music]
it's never too late to come over time
slips away from you and me now and
that's that Stevie starlight man and
honestly that song make my crotch just
crawl around my body boy that's that why
that song you'll find your dick hanging
out under your arm you know you'll find
your tits mingling down by your ankles
you know because it cuz they scurried
off of your sternum and that's a stevie
starlight it's just something about that
song it just you know and I got reminded
because I got this message on social
media this week here's the message hey
Theo 25 year old long-haul truck driver
out of Kentucky which to me out of the
gate seemed very alarming a 25 year old
driving big rig out of the K talk boy
who I hope you got a hope you got
collision just want to say thanks for
helping me get my swag back I now bump
that Stevie starlight if you ever see a
trucker with no shirt and his nipples
pierced don't be surprised to hear that
Stevie starlight and man when you when
you sent me that message whoever that
was it might have been on Instagram when
you sent me that message you just I mean
you filled me up baby you really did
never too late to come over
why must we wait
you heard that LUN why must we wait when
we are alive that's Stevie starlight
guys it is March 5 March 5 Monday March
5 and year 2017 and I'm in the new
studio but it's quite look I mean if
you're looking on the YouTube you see
the new studio it probably looks
familiar because of the fighter and the
kid and that is a very popular podcast
with two men mr. Brian Collins and he is
the kid even though he's he is an adult
he's very he's double the age of a legal
adult and then the other man is named
Brendan Schaub and he is a he's like an
Instagram model who you know he's also
like a spokesperson any use to wrestle
and these men are they have a phenomenal
podcast and it's called the fighter and
the kid and and I've been on there and
now here I am back in their old studio
their studio they moved up there
accelerating you know they're taking
things to that extra level and they got
a bigger space and they're their old
space was available and you know a
little bit of homage to them I said you
know I'm gonna take the space so I took
over that lease I want to thank you to
my patreon errs who have been supportive
you got if it weren't for you guys would
not be in this new position and this is
going to be this going to be our new
home for this past weekend right here so
we got a real place we're gonna be able
to have hopefully guests come in and not
have to do this into my into my kitchen
you know not have to do this in the in
the dining room because it was just
getting hectic you know my windows were
all covered up to keep the light you
know equal in the apartment and it was
just getting wild and so this will give
me a chance to you know to uh to this to
have a space that's that's for us I mean
it does feel good immediately I mean
look we're gonna decorate it different I
know if you're seeing it they still have
a lot of firing they have like their
woodwork on the back wall and this
beautiful portrait of Venice on one of
the walls and you know some things are
going to change some things going to get
adjusted by
I mean this is honestly personally this
one to kind of the bravest things I've
ever done
you know because part of me you know the
podcast was just starting to make a make
a little bit of money you know just
starting to have a little bit of extra
money in the account at the end of each
month to you know go out there and get a
pack of snow cones you know or find a
couple local children emboss buy my um
you know a box of uh you know chocolate
cones or you know a box of sugar snaps
or something but now but I had to say
well look I can try and advance in and
take that extra step and that's what I
did I took that extra step and for me
it's just brave and I you know I'm the
guy grew up in that you know I grew up
in you know if you had something you
[ __ ] had it everything I had was
hidden growing up you ever do that man
soon as groceries would come to the
house hide hide that hide that my mom
come on woke me up one morning like what
the [ __ ] you up here sleeping with a
half gallon of milk
I say gang gang mama you know gang gang
because it you know that was just it
whatever came in you would get because
you wanted to have your stuff you needed
you needed things to be yours and and
you were just scared you know you
working living from that place of fear
and so you know to be here today in you
know in and and having you know some
listenership and moving up and that's
what we're doing we're just going onward
you know what I'm saying because it's
never too late baby
[Music]
yes never too late
you heard him it's never too late to
come over to come over to the side of
you know what let's do this next step
let's accelerate and we got a couple of
calls people knew you know I put the the
YouTube video up last week that's why
there wasn't a Thursday episode because
things had to be moved here I was at a
wedding all weekend in New Orleans
visiting my family you know we took the
girls out to the dinosaur extravaganza
or something out there you know we we
got got a box of Jimmy John's from mom
and mr. Charlie from the war you know he
was in a war and he's still you know
mentally he's always going to bad I mean
we're driving down the highway and my
mom's husband is sitting in the shotgun
seat and he's you know firing invisible
guns at people as we're passing on the
highway you know he's still he's
flashing back and he's allowed to do
that you know he's in his 80s so he's
allowed to you know he's allowed to
stretch out a little bit mentally but he
starts you know sending in other troops
and [ __ ] like that when we're turning
corners it gets a little it gets a
little real I mean it gets a little bit
call of duty if they had call of duty
but you could pick a character is like
80 years old and you know wears a hat
with like a bunch of World War 2 and
Revolutionary War pins on that on the
hat on the brim of it then that would be
him and that's mr. Charlie and he was in
the war and that's my mother's husband
so I spent time there and we did all
that a couple calls came in man and I'm
gonna play them just real fast right
here and these are just about the about
the new studio here we go hey brother
congratulate on the new studio looks
cool [ __ ] yeah congratulations
Gang Gang onward all that good stuff but
uh man don't don't change your style
brother people love listen to you blow
and you know do your little bee thing
and ain't little man side of me say that
dude I'm being a [ __ ] today you
know it's do you thing man it's amazing
not everybody can do that [ __ ] do it the
way you do it so stay true to yourself
well I appreciate that man and you
weren't being a punk you know I feel
that sometimes too if I use a certain
adverb or adjective
you know that that uh that I'm being
offensive sometimes or whatever but not
man this is a little thing it is you
know it's just a little thing and and
I'm excited and we took a little step
forward and so that's what we're doing
and I appreciate that man
you know appreciate you making the call
you decided to call and say
congratulations to somebody else and man
if we are if everybody did that every
day if everybody was giving a call and
getting a call to somebody else to say
look way to go for anything I don't care
if somebody just took a deep breath or
if somebody want a [ __ ] gold medal if
everybody was dropping that call man I
think we'd all all be feeling good but I
appreciate that you know I appreciate
that
one more call right there
and this that Denny shooter right here
this gentleman called in a while back
and he had shot up a dinner he had been
a a passenger in a car that shot up a
Denny's go on video congratulations my
man congratulations
proud of you thank you for everything we
do you're amazing okay well you inflate
my ego there at the end but you know I
appreciate the sentiment and I am
excited I'm excited because it gives
gives us a space it's almost like having
a home you know it's almost like it's
almost like having a home that's what it
feels like a little bit you know Chris
Perez he was working you know he came
yesterday and got all the stuff out of
my apartment and brought it over here
you know and he's out here sidekicking
and helping out and and and it was you
know I wanted to make a video before I
left the old studio and just like a you
know a little sentimental kind of thing
because I always been a scrapbooker you
know low-key honestly I always have been
a scrapbooker I've always collected
little pieces of this and that and put
them away somewhere you know because I
think I was afraid growing up that I
didn't you know I just uh I think my dad
was so old that he didn't remember
anything
you know my dad didn't remember anything
I mean my dad was born in 1910 his
father was born in 1880 my grandfather
was born in 1880 so my dad by the time I
met him in nineteen you know born in 80
but you know probably started talking to
him in about 85 86 87 he didn't really
remember that much from being a kid you
know so part of me I wanted to save
little pieces of everything so that when
I have a child one day that they will
you know if something happens where I
can't remember that they'll at least be
able to have little things that will you
know little bread crumbs that'll help
them kind of Hansel and Gretel through
my past and and and this and what was I
saying Jesus dude I might be I don't
know what this is called amny no not
emphasis I don't know what this is man
but I just has always happens to me I
start talking and I can't [ __ ] I'm
gonna talking about oh man it makes me
mad but anyhow man [ __ ] it bro whatever
dude thanks for calling that guy shot up
a Denny's with some people and and you
know on where we go oh it feels like a
home now you know it feels like a home
and I always you know I saved little
pieces of uh growing up and everything
in scrapbooks I've always been a
scrapbooker so I wanted to have that
video of myself in the old studio the
last moments you know just kind of you
know a farewell little video but you
know I didn't do it and uh Chris the
sidekick it was like look man I can help
you get you know stuff out of there
while you're out of town and I said all
right man go in there you know go into
my place and get and I get over here and
things are halfway set up and we're
going to evolve look this is a and I
want to know what do you guys want to
see in the studio so if you want to hit
up on Twitter if you want to hit up on
Instagram put it in the comments on
YouTube what do you kind of want to see
in the studio because I have some ideas
you know we're gonna do some things but
if there's one or two things you want to
see you know we're an idea that you have
I'm certainly open to it you know we
have to figure out what the best format
is for like interviewing guests
you know how to do it you sit somebody
over there do you sit across from them
how am I gonna feel most comfortable you
know I can't even record with somebody
in the studio right now that's where I'm
at so I'm that [ __ ] you know I'm that
counting that kennel cat that's
corralling in the corner you know I'm
that kennel cat that's correct that you
know that that was raised by you know a
couple of shotguns you know he got a
shotgun for a daddy and a shotgun for a
momma because if you go in there like a
kennel sometime you see you see all you
see a couple cats and they're hugging
you know they might have one cat who's
[ __ ] you know jerking off or who you
know maybe you have a cat who's like
kind of you know disguised his own tail
like a dick and he's like you know
jerking it off or summer you know
letting another chick kind of touch it
or taste it or something but then you
got the and you got other cats that are
juggling you got a couple cats playing
soccer or whatever you got a cat that's
got fleas do but a couple of other chick
cats are still [ __ ] with him because
he's got money but then you had that one
cat over in the corner and he's a little
bit scared you know he's got his back he
has to have he's picks a corner because
he has to have his back against two
walls some of us will you bleed the only
place we can survive is with our back
against the wall and this little kitten
he gotta have his back against two walls
and uh and he you know he can only feel
you know he can only feel energetic
right there in that in that intersection
and and that's that you know that's me
man raised by shotguns you know that you
know I just I feel better if nobody's in
if nobody's in the room with me it just
makes me feel I'm more comfortable and I
guess it makes me feel like I'm with you
as opposed to if somebody's here in the
room that I'm here with them you know
and we might try to do something more
like that on the Thursday episodes but
but here we are man we're in the new
studio and I want to say thank you so
much you know we hit the patron goal
this on March 1st of a thousand bucks
and that got us into the studio so I'm
just super grateful and I just can't
believe this happening you know we're
making we're making something cool and
I'm you know I'm trying to delve into
this and
this this shouldn't get more real and
stay in the pocket and see what's going
on you know and like that man said that
called in he said don't change your
style you know and I'm gonna try not to
do that so I went to a I went to a
wedding this weekend I wouldn't spend
telling my family you know when I went
down to Louisiana we had a good time and
we had a good time down in Louisiana my
mother was down there and her you know
they got they had a dead animal in the
house and so you know my mom didn't want
me coming over because she don't like
having me over
I guess if they got dead animals in the
attic and I don't know what kind of
animal it was it wasn't anything
exciting you know wasn't like a [ __ ]
Lynx or anything like that or a
Louisiana black bear it was probably a
you know basic animal a bird that got
stuck in there raccoon possum some just
run-of-the-mill straight up gutter
animal you know I mean raccoons are
basically the homeless people of the
animal kingdom when you really think
about it the [ __ ] out there at night
struggling they dressed up like burglars
basic ass burglars dude they're dressed
up they're not even dressed up like real
like classy new burglars they're dressed
up like like but like just but the
[ __ ] most basic burglars that you
would see in like in a movie from like
the 40s or something you know they're
dressed up like just fake-ass
hamburglars that's what they look like
and you know so probably one of them
dead in the attic or whatever blah blah
blah what else man we took the girl
I took got us a box of sandwiches you
know I hit up that Jimmy John and got a
box of sandwiches for my mother and she
never had a Jimmy John's sandwich I mean
the thing about you get something for my
mom and you it's new she never had it do
show I asked you a million questions Oh
wonder were this brightest prom Oh who's
it named after I don't [ __ ] know
Jimmy John I don't know some dude who
gots two names for the first name
so man it just [ __ ] was heavy man you
know and that's when I just I gotta
learn to practice some patience man you
know my mom asked me stuff sometimes it
just takes me back to when I was a kid
and my mom would nag on me immediately I
go inside I just go right there and I'm
just a frustrated kid you know next
thing you know I'm you know off hanging
out behind a Jimmy John's with a couple
of fourteen-year-old dishwashers smoking
cigarettes you know trying to get my
feelings out of my body trying to get my
angry feelings out of my body but we
went what else do we do man I spent time
with my nieces and my nephews man I'm
you know I'm really lucky man you know
really you know I I feel really lucky to
I guess it's like you know I feel lucky
to be around children and you know be
somebody that people trust and that
might sound crazy but I grew in my
neighborhood when I was growing up dude
you would you know I'm saying if you
didn't like there's always that things
stay away from strangers but in some
instance in some neighborhoods
everybody's a [ __ ] stranger where
everybody acts like it a little better
people are always kind of showing up or
passing through and you don't know you
know and you'd even be over by your
friends house and their uncle or aunt
would be over or their step encore
somebody who's [ __ ] somebody and you
you know you not that you could their
parents would tell you look y'all play
hide-and-seek but it don't let you know
Uncle Mark find you and you're like what
the [ __ ] well maybe we shouldn't play
they be like nah nah y'all play like and
we will you know it's just like but I
guess I feel you know I feel fortunate
to be that family member that I'm cool
you know I'm good I'm okay around the
kids you know they trust me to take the
kids you know I can dry you know I drove
my my niece and nephews 34 team I can
drive him you know and I guess I don't
know my mom always worried my dad was so
old man my mom always worried about him
anytime he would drive us you know
that's that risk you take
that's that risk boy
you know my dad I mean it there was no
that dude he couldn't turn his neck he
could not turn his neck man and so we
tell him I remember being five years old
at the most and telling him which way if
the light was red or green and you know
how easy could mess that up when you're
a kid you don't [ __ ] know the only
way you even know red and green is
because you've been through four
Christmases
siren being five years old and having no
idea you know amber and one time he had
to look down this how I remember
standing on his leg putting both of my
feet on the side of his leg grabbing on
his chin and it's how cuz his neck was
just so tight that's why he couldn't
turn it you know when he's 76 75 years
old at this time and just pulling on his
chin leaning out away from his leg just
as hard as I could just like you know
like you're hanging off the side of a
boat like holding onto a rope or
something I just remember you know
trying to turn his neck over to the
right so he could see down this Highway
just a bunch of [ __ ] Muppet work just
a bunch of Muppet work being you know
and that uh you know it was just you
know so it's nice just to be around
family and being around kids and make
jokes with my nephews and just I don't
know man there's a lot of fun yeah I
never you know I've always found joy in
that but I never found much joy as I did
this time for some reason and maybe it's
because they're getting a little bit
older you know the two or three year old
you know when you hear something about
their you know you hear something bad
happens to a child you understand it you
don't understand it it's wack you know
but if you if you one day if a parent
were like you know what I'll [ __ ] drop
my two-year-old off in the [ __ ] woods
they gave him a tenth get my igloo
cooler a couple of lanterns and say [ __ ]
you bruh I would almost understand that
from a parent I would almost be like you
know what I could understand that
because kids at that age meant they're
just they just cracked out the egg you
don't know what they don't have any idea
what's going on so it's nice to be
around with a little bit older man and
we can play games and just do fun stuff
we could joke around they tell me jokes
you know we just had fun man and they
had Cat in the Hat
day at school and one of my name's sakes
my dad told me was a theá-- dr. Seuss
his real name was Theodore and you know
he told me that that was a name that he
had that influenced him and named him me
Theodore Geisel March 2nd that's when he
was born Theodore Geisel dr. Seuss and
so they had dr. Seuss day at that little
school preschool and [ __ ] and I'm
rolling up there my little nephew and
he's probably [ __ ] I don't know man he
might be 4 I don't know I'm he's real
small you know a few worse I mean he
definitely looks like a kid he looked
you know you know he's a kid when you
see him you don't think he's like a
little adult like a little you know like
a [ __ ] or something gigantism you
think he's a child but he are whatever
he was dressed up like Cat in the Hat
and we go to the kids going all these
kids man I'm running around just like
the Grinch and thing one and [ __ ] one
kid dressed up like Rudolph some kid
that [ __ ] it up everybody's Cat in the
Hat and this dude is Rudolph man what
the hell man so but it was something
Louisiana at its finest dude we went out
to some exhibit thing took my niece to
some dinosaur fair and they got all
these inflatable dinosaurs and kids
getting head lice and [ __ ]
some kid vomited on the slide and stuff
you got a some two adults [ __ ]
beating each other with corn dogs with
hard corn dogs off in the distance just
I mean and if people are short as [ __ ]
do you get out there to south Louisiana
man some of these people everybody look
like they should be a jockey on a horse
everybody look like they're that height
that they maybe maybe rode there on a
horse like you got a Baba but you got a
6% chance that people [ __ ] giddyup to
get there and everybody I mean it just
looks I don't know everybody looked the
same I ever seemed like they were just
you know they had a small hat full of
genetics and there was only a couple
genes in there and you got to pick one
of those out of a hat you know they had
some real juice I mean I'm look I'm
there's one thing to look wild you know
there's one thing maybe you born with
three legs or something you know what
I'm nothing
[ __ ] I'm a healthy 8 I'm an 8 you
know I got a big nose I got a
gender-neutral hairstyle I got a short
neck I got medium arms I missed you know
I'm coming in lackluster in a lot of
places I got the butt of a of a young
black girl with Down syndrome you know I
got them hips like that I got them you
know I got that des booty you know but
when you start mixing genetics and you
start mixing matching you know the T GAC
and all that [ __ ] that's supposed to be
in the cells and you start Criss
crossing things up I mean they had some
people just the Traveling Wilburys of
genetics you know you expecting some Roy
Orbison are you expecting but then you
get a little bit everything and you're
like damn I didn't know all these uh
band members played together and
suddenly they did and that's what you
got with some of the genetics down there
you know you got them Traveling Wilburys
and who was in that band and my mother
used to listen to that band when I was
growing up all the time George Harrison
Tom Petty Bob Dylan Roy Orbison Jeff
Lynn Jeff Keltner can you listen to the
Traveling Wilburys if you never listen
to them and you love music but that but
that's kind of what you think you're
like oh yeah somebody put too many too
many band members in this band and
that's what you get him you saw a dude I
saw a dude out there spitting in the air
catching in his mouth like that's not uh
and that's like just kind of like
juggling I guess but it's not but we had
fun man you know we just took the kids
out and you know just nice to be I don't
know man maybe I'm [ __ ] growing up a
little it was nice just to be you know
they came to me if the kids wanted you
know they they wanted somebody to watch
them do this or they want you know they
need help with something or they you
know they come and ask the dog and they
know I made you know they know I guess
they start to know in themselves that
they that I'm reliable and so I guess in
a weird way man it's the first time that
I felt like maybe that's it maybe it's
like the first time that I felt like
reliable you know in my life
so I don't know managed to get this new
this new studio got me emotional in here
dude that's Brendan Schaub right there
you know I'm saying that dude was hehehe
getting kind of emo he got on ninety
dollar socks the other day yeah that's
$45 a foot it's a foot Brendan Schaub
not a wallet each foot ain't supposed to
be worth a high amount of money that's
$45 a foot but it felt good to be with
family man it felt good you know it's
hard being a family member you know it's
hard especially you didn't I pray I
don't have practice growing up so when I
getting it now son Gang Gang but we're
in the new studio and I'm grateful a lot
of people was asking about I see Mike
you know I was on Joey Diaz his podcast
last week the Church of what's happening
now and if you don't have an uncle or
you don't have a big brother or are you
own are your husband's I'm straight-up
worse go go listen to the Church of
what's happening now you know Joey Diaz
does a special thing and I don't and I
don't know if it's part of his plan or
not but he has this weird ability no
it's not weird I'm sorry that's not the
word he has this ability to just to make
you feel he just cares man he cares
about a lot of people and you feel that
when you go in there you feel that when
you go in there and and I'm just
grateful we had a great time in there
people are asking about I see Mike and
this man I see Mike was this man when I
was growing up in my neighborhood they
had this dude I see I see Mike and he
would always get these what he would get
water from different parts of the
country and he freeze it at his house
and so in the summertime you know in the
summertime we go over to his house and
have different types of ice from
different places you know we have you
know he'd have all kind of stuff you
know
salt water brackish you know he'd have
uh you know something that had a little
too much mercury in it you know some
illegal [ __ ] he'd have some Lake Mead a
little bit of you know um
Gulf of Mexico that's you know that's
easy we have a different river you know
the Tchefuncte Choctaw I remember one
year he got a couple buckets of the
Colorado and he would freeze it into
chunks and we'd go over his house and
eat it and kind of you know it's like a
little vacation it was a little bit of a
vacation because some people got to
travel a lot and when I grew up you
wasn't traveling anywhere did nobody
took it man I remember this pedophile
due to this trucker his long-haul
trucker put me and my buddy Michael and
Michael had some deficiencies he had
extra salivary glands and his face needs
to leak out of his mouth and he had a
sitting in his truck playing again
playing a game of how many tootsie rolls
could we each put in our mouths dude and
then assert a young age you think it's
just a fun game you know and you know
and I'm putting some in Mike's mafias
putting them in each other's mouths you
know and we don't have an idea where
children you know we eleven year old
children and so we sitting in the cab of
this 18-wheeler putting that this dude
that we met off of a CB radio this man
showed up in the neighborhood off of a
ham radio and this dude pulls up next
thing you know me a [ __ ] drippy my
car sitting in this Michael Michael I
don't want to say the boy's name but he
but anyhow he um this man had us putting
putting tootsie rolls and he chose
mouthing counting how many we could get
into each other's mouths and I'm not
saying something's wrong with that but
I'm saying something's wrong with that
you freaking creep I hope that man just
I don't know I hope something bad
happened that man cuz you're not
supposed to do that and that's the kind
of thing see I'm not doing that kind of
[ __ ] with kids I'm not out there playing
stupid games with candy you know I'm a
safe reliable person around children and
family and this man had me and [ __ ]
drippy Mike Michael putting these in
each other's mouths man and Michael
little Michael put about man this dude
had I think he probably put about 17
into his mouth I put about 11 in and he
put about six in himself and I'll tell
you this truck drivers sitting there
probably hard as [ __ ] dude
because that dude was probably a damn
creep but thank God man this other this
guy named Clint you know like
kind of like [ __ ] but with an in Clint
he came and he whooped that man's ass
when he saw that man had us in his truck
cab and I'm thankful to that man and
that was I'm pretty grateful for that
but yeah this but anyhow this dude I see
Mike would have us over to have
different ices you know for because when
you were young you didn't travel much
and what I was saying was that trucker
that picked up me and this other kid
Michael drippy Michael he used to uh he
he offered to take us to Florida and
when I was growing up Florida was the
only place to go when you grew up in
Louisiana if you met somebody who'd been
up Colorado or something that didn't
make any sense to you you're like what
how did sure guy okay okay sure
Buzz Aldrin sure you went to Colorado
but if because the only place to go
growing up in the south was Florida that
was it where have you been at Florida
where you headed Florida if you saw
somebody to come in from school Cameron
from summer break and they had a t-shirt
on this head floor it on it with a
picture of the son of petrova of a palm
tree and a beach and a little sunset
good chance whoever was wearing that was
gonna do some [ __ ] in that year because
that's us that shirt shows that they
have been somewhere they I've been
traveling you see some of this other
[ __ ] Wisconsin you're like what is that
Wisconsin is that a church what is that
you know what happened because in the
south you know when you're in the south
you just Yili but you grew up with a lot
of tradition and everything is very
traditional and you keep it small like
that I'm sure it's the same for like
Missouri like Lake of the Ozarks or you
know like in Wisconsin like um or
Michigan like upstate Michigan you know
like um the Upper Peninsula or something
like that or over on North Carolina and
South Carolina like probably the Outer
Banks you know like the does this these
places where that's where people went
for vacations and so that's what we kind
of um you know that was the only place
to go growing up was Florida the only
place to go was Florida so I was out
talking about
I don't know what happened oh so I see
Mike would get these places would get
these treats you know this frozen water
we go over there he'd freeze up a batch
of it and break it up with a hammer and
we'd all be sitting over there eating a
little bit of um you know foreign water
something something from somewhere else
and it was pretty good man it was a nice
treat cuz for us that was like taking a
vacation you know we might not get to
like a you know Lake Minnetonka
but that doesn't mean that we weren't
gonna have a crush sack of it you know
and be you know you know take the end of
it you know to get the bag at the end
you got little bit of water left in your
bag you ate all the ice you just
dripping the water on each other's bare
backs and [ __ ] like that and being chill
and just and you know it was like a
chance to take a vacation without having
to go anywhere having them exotic ices
and this dude I see Mike and I talked
about that on coke OD as his podcast you
can you can listen to that podcast and
check it out more and if you're not
familiar with him which I think a lot of
podcast listeners are he really is he
really is I don't know if he's in he's
not a soothe you know what he's kind of
a soothsayer he's a he's a voice that
you trust and there's something there's
something beautiful about that there's
something beautiful about that oh I hear
in this new studio boy I got room I can
come here tomorrow you know I don't have
to I don't have to like you know the
other place from at the house man and if
somebody comes over you my whole dining
room had been turned in the studio so if
somebody you know doing you know doing a
[ __ ] or somebody's you know cooking up
some broccoli or something the whole
studio stinks you know even I live alone
and if the only person who would be
doing shits and doing broccoli is me but
still I didn't want to say me but here
you know they got a bathroom down the
hall they got all kind of opportunity so
I'm happy to be here caught up in this
man I'm happy to be here and caught up
in this all right let's get to this
wedding I was in this I was at this
wedding and dude I'm racing around the
French Quarter and uh you know I'm
trying to you know a buddy of mine and I
invested in a place down there a while
back and I
find the code to the door and all that
his [ __ ] and so next you know I'm locked
out I'm running around a j.crew trying
to find a you know a Bell tuna and uh
some slacks and just some kind of
[ __ ] you know at the last minute run
to the sweat and get there 40 seconds
before it starts and and it was funny
well I mean you know it was funny man it
was funny to be there you know a lot of
guys that I grew up with there's a guy
in my hometown who and I say this a lot
I mean this kind of makes I'm not trying
to make this about me but you know he
was getting married and he is if I was
better-looking I would be him he looks
like me but better looking like people
would seem like I guess would meet him
and then see me it meet me later and be
like oh man what's going on dude did you
get stung by bees because I look like
him if he got stung by a bunch of bees
like in the face that's kind of how we
look but it was great man we went there
and you know there's something cool
about seeing your buddy
you know get emotional I have some
feelings up there you know and he's
Gleek and out of his eye sockets a
little bit you know he's feeling that
love and then his lady comes banging in
at a courtyard and she's all dolled up
you know she got on a couple thousand
dollar dress out there they skirting out
running around looking like um I mean it
looked like somebody you know those
doilies you know rich people they don't
want to set their cup on the table
because they don't like the sound of it
that's imagine how rich some people got
to the point where the sound of a cup
hitting a table bothered them so they
had to put down a doily
well her dress it looked like they'd
taken a lot of those fancy nice doilies
and made a nice dress out of him you
know she looked I mean she came out and
you're like dang you know I'd set a
million cups on this little lady you
know what I'm saying
and I'm not I mean I'm not you know
trying to holler at the lady I'm just
saying she looked lovely and it was nice
her we just had a good time was that
wedding it was that wedding you know
that wedding fever and and this you know
you know my buddy that got married he's
you know he's a handsome guy and I'm
like [ __ ] man this dude I couldn't help
but feeling for one moment I'm like damn
is he uh he is brave that's what I
thought
he's brave because that's what it seemed
like to me getting married a lot you
know you clamping in and we were talking
about that on the last episode and it
was just so funny that I was at a
wedding because you're clamping in and
then there's only I realize there's only
a few at this point I'm certain I was
only a few of my friends like my friends
from home that aren't married and you
start getting narrowed into a into a
circle of friends so it comes to point
the only people you're friends with or
the people who aren't married so it's
like damn you know guess I'm friends
with [ __ ] Donald cuz he can got
nobody you know or guess I'm friends
with Lamont because he blind and he
ain't got nobody so next thing you know
you down to just a motley crew it's just
like you know it's you is [ __ ] you
know big Donald with that thing on his
neck is blind [ __ ] Alan and you just
get you get narrow down into just the
few people who aren't married dozy your
friends that's it because it's anybody's
wife anybody with a wife isn't gonna let
him be friends with somebody who don't
have a wife and I don't blame them
I don't blame them at all I don't blame
him at all so it was it was interesting
man we had fun that we did some dancing
do my buddies daddy can [ __ ] dance
this dude I'm gonna call him sometime
and have him on the podcast I might even
try to do it on Wednesday just to get
some stories out of him this man this
dude Lamar he'll drop leg brah
dude I'm watching him I think I said at
one point I'm like Tim he got six legs
his [ __ ] stub at his step that he's a
damn caterpillar because this man got
six legs and we had fun man we danced
you know I danced a little I can't do it
man I get tired easy it used to be like
four hours of Rage and you know couple
tabs or Molly whatever would make me
now like you know a big muffin and I got
a slowed it down but it was it man it
was it was just it was wild to see and
was especially wild because we're
talking about weddings last week you
know we crackin into that wedding in
that wedding bliss you know we've been
talking about it we had a man named geo
that called the podcast last week I'm
gonna tap into his call right here here
we go New York just call him with a
question
all right Gio thank you for calling burr
like this oh we're done with a few years
now she's always talked about she wanted
to get married you know marry them
marriage is something that I've never
really saw a benefit to you know I never
knew what was the reason I get mad yeah
you love each other you get married I
love you you love me
we both know we love each other you know
what benefit is getting married gonna do
for it do you know like okay and that
was gos callin that was on last episode
and a couple people responded so I want
to hit a couple of these responses right
here you know see you guys can feel kind
of what Tom you know you just can see
what uh I want to hear what some of the
suggestions and thought you had to Gio's
question you know why why get married
these days what's the what's of what's
it worth what's the value in it here we
go
what's up CEO Brian from Bonita Springs
Brian from bonitas Springs and I'm I
don't know where that is but it sounds a
lightly Latino and the Nicaraguan part
of me says viola onward I'm calling in
about the guy with his questions on if
he should get married married and what's
the benefits I'm kind of going through
the exact same thing as he is I've been
with a girl for a little while now and
we're expecting our first daughter in
May
okay so you got that May baby you know
they say sometime they say different
babies are from you know that when
you're born determines you'll behave
differently you know the Stars the moon
horoscopes all that kind of magical [ __ ]
all that kind of stuff to have you
buying it fares and everything and I
don't know about that
you know it's like they tell you to
believe in like a constellation and next
you notice there's a shooting star
you're like what the [ __ ]
you know half of Orion's belt just went
out of business so something that's kind
of hard for me to believe but I have
always believed that if you were born in
certain months or certain times of the
year that you are better at certain
sexual positions so a Sagittarius might
you know get that doggy style more
comfortably than if you got some fake
ass Capricorn trying to jerk you off
somewhere all right let's hear a little
bit more and I kind of told her in the
beginning that I did want to marry her
but I didn't want to do it during the
pregnancy because I wanted it to be
special in its own right okay so you did
want to marry her but you don't want to
do it during the present pregnancy
because you want it to be special in its
own right this sounds it sounds like
something I would not accept if I'm a
woman but let's hear more so I know
she's gonna kind of be expecting to get
married sometime in the near future too
and now that I've said that to her I've
been thinking the same thing as him you
know I don't know if I want to get the
government involved Wow
more of and so to kind of paint the
picture my thoughts are you know if we
love each other and we're gonna be
together forever or at least for until
our child grows up then I don't think
it's that important you know as long as
your child has a stable mom and a stable
dad that are working together I don't I
don't think it's that important look I
appreciate you calling that's look those
are some real points daddy can't those
are some real points those are some
legit meows because if you like yeah but
the thing is how are you gonna convince
her that you already told her after the
pregnancy you know I'm saying there's
only so long you can keep that baby in
there
ten months I had a buddy that stayed in
for ten months and I'll tell you this
dude he's an [ __ ] he's a complete
[ __ ]
and I know another guy that you know who
this dude held a premature this dude
Daryl that I grew up with and he you
know you don't want that early early
baby because he might you know Daryl
might grow to 80 years old but he's
never gonna hit nine months if you know
I'm saying you know his jaw and his neck
are all kind of the same thing
everything he's kind of you know he's
like a one-piece he's like a one-piece
swimsuit but he's a person you know I'm
saying like everything kind of like he
could put on a shirt and it's like his
whole body is kind of covered you know
he like he look like one it like
something Jim hints and withdraw so you
want to make sure that the baby is just
you don't want to you know try to
shorten that or lengthen that based on
to keep some promise that you've made
and look man and if you come out up with
this it with this because at this point
it's just gonna seem like an excuse I'm
just from up from what I think I think
it to her at this point it's just gonna
seem like an excuse you got this baby
coming I mean I agree with you let's
just be loved you know let's just be in
love and take care of this this kid but
people want the women and some well you
got they want you to put your nuts it
they want you to put your pink slip on
the line you know it's kind of like when
you would race those race cars or people
would rate you know race race cars or
you know you know we didn't used to have
this thing where people would race and
uh you know get their kids outside and
race them make the kids race each other
and bet on the children in our
neighborhood and but it's like there's
pay the pink slips with the cars you
race the cars you put the pink slip
don't down because if you don't put the
pink slip down then you can say yeah
winner gets the car when it gets my car
when it gets your car but you could just
renege on that and that's not a racial
slur either but you could just renege on
that at the end and that's what's going
on I think is that what people are
saying is put your nuts on the line put
your nuts on the guillotine unless let's
play chop chop
because otherwise you're just saying
you're gonna but you know but another
school a beautiful school of thought is
why do we need this and I'll tell you
why is because it makes you it puts your
skin in the game that's it it puts your
skin in the game it's the same as like
out you know when I do a comedy showing
the tickets have all been given away to
the show you don't know what to expect
people you know vomiting in there you
know vomiting in their purse one lady
vomited in her purse you know one dude
came up on stage when I can came out of
the closet in front of half the crowd if
some people threw some [ __ ] at him like
who cares dude nobody gives a [ __ ] that
you're gay let's go the [ __ ] isn't about
you you know I'm saying so just you know
sit down Gavin this [ __ ] ain't about you
but it's like when you when you give
away all the tickets you doesn't matter
but when people pay for the tickets to
the show that audience pays attention
that audience is there to pay attention
and that's why I think you that's why
you go in it like that that's why you go
in it like that
but I respect look man I feel for you
you got the lady you got the baby coming
at this point I'll just put eyes on the
baby and just try to be honest and say
what you mean but don't say it mean
that's what someone told me recently
that's been resonating with me say what
you mean but don't say it mean and
because you can have to take out if
you're gonna really have a B if you're
gonna get more honest with your lady
about this and you're gonna have to be
extremely careful how you discuss it you
know and if you think it's just fears if
you think it's another woman if you
think it's just fears maybe try and just
tell her look this is what my fears are
I love you but I'm afraid of this see if
you can sound it out maybe you'll come
to some conclusions even just by
sounding it out for your lady you know
I'm saying got something you got to spit
up in the air and let it land in
somebody else's mouth and that's the
truth that's what that's called that's
called firing that truth because if you
just keep spitting and catching it
yourself
you know that's easy to do because
that's just recycling idea someone's got
to drop that truth next door and and see
how it tastes when you set it into
somebody else's when you set it into
somebody else's mouth all right let's
hear another response that came in for
Gio's inquiry about why marriage now hey
cor just wanted to call in about the
marriage topic and I don't know why
anybody does it anymore
because more people get divorced than
people that stay together in marriages
that's true you know more people get
divorced in a stay together in marriages
I think that's true that's Oh everybody
says there's a lot of people are
divorced there's a lot of people also
they give up on [ __ ] everything half
of America has tried to get a real
estate license and [ __ ] bailed out
after they got the course completion so
you know we're you know we're fickle
more statistically that's true and once
you marry a woman it gets rid of
incentive to stay with the person they
marry because if they leave the
relationship they get half of the man's
[ __ ] so how does that work you can just
let yourself go get fat take the trash
out no you just don't have to do
anything and it's like yeah [ __ ]
dumped me because if you dumped me I get
half your [ __ ] I don't know it just
seems like a death trap to me man now
he's got now that's a contractual point
right there yeah you signed the papers I
think they need to put some ah you know
some decency limits in there for every
crunch I do you got to do a crunch you
know for every week then I eat you got
to eat a wheat thin because if you out
there just [ __ ] you know you know
juggling uh you know if you out there
just juggling [ __ ] you know high
sodium Lunchables on your tongue all
week and you out there just sneaking in
[ __ ] hit some Lunchables in the
middle of the night and keeping
Lunchables up under your pillow and all
of that and hiding you know hot and
lunchable
a [ __ ] ice cooler in the bathroom
under the sink in doing all that and
special chocolates and you blowing up
and I'm out here doing celery and
carrots
that's not fair it's not fair and
especially if you just milling around in
circles so maybe it's uh maybe that's
the truth maybe people need to start
putting in these in these these legal
agreements hey this is we're gonna stay
within this health range that's just but
then you know what it is in the end it
just comes back more - it's just me you
know what can hey you know if somebody
does that to you that's ice cold but
you're right in the eye you they go get
a good lawyer if you know a man gets fat
on you or it gets out of shape on you or
doesn't care about himself and I say get
fat I'm sorry about that that's an easy
one you know I found myself I was
looking at myself in the mirror
yesterday and I look like a young
alcoholic cut my guts starting to look
for my dick you ever notice when that
happens when your gut starts just
looking for your dick it starts kind of
just pointing forward he's getting
longer and I noticed my gut starts
looking for my day and I could just see
how it some of it just happens you get
busy working and your body changes and
stuff and you just got to be in love I
think you know that's one of the things
you just got to be in love somebody
texted me and said I can't remember who
it was they said you just gotta ask
yourself can you be without this person
can you be without them and if the
answer is that you can be without them
then they're not the one and I don't
know if that's a [ __ ] real good
statement or not but that's what I heard
but there you go Geo there's a couple
schools that thought there's a couple
schools that thought you know in this in
this if when we live in this me universe
now and it's all about us and it's all
about me me me you know how much are we
really there for the other person when
they struggle you know if they're you
know give they're not taking care of
themselves
- just turn the other cheek and look the
other way I know it's hard as hell to be
uninfluenced by sex or by I mean
advertising the way that they I mean
Nate advertisers have got us it should
be illegal to advertise the way that
they do it should be illegal
I mean they are hitting us with every
titty and crotch bulge and shoulder
nipples I saw something on the internet
the other day some lady got nipples put
into her shoulders real nipples so you
could look at her arms and be thinking
about tits and if that isn't a
bait-and-switch style of business I
don't know what is and it's just you
know we're so influenced to as a you
know as a man you're just you're so
you're so triggered constantly by sex
look over here look at these billboards
strippers you know pase pase buzz hey
casinos vaginas it's just that it's a
mate you know it's amazing we're not all
just driving around just jerking off in
our cars and getting into car accidents
which a lot of us are doing a lot of us
are doing that but it's amazing it's not
happening more at kind of a higher rate
that should be an Olympic sport run and
jerk off till you come and then tag your
buddy you know that's it the comes
hassle on well not everybody though is
as influenced by sex some people want to
be we had a young lady that called in a
while back Danielle the virgin she
called in and and this was her call you
guys might remember it you guys might
not but we're actually going to she hit
the hotline which is nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three she hit
the hotline and and spoke and said hey
do I want you to give me a call so I'm
gonna call her in just a minute I first
want to play for you her original call
this is a few months back let's hear it
hey Theo my name is junior
I am 25 and a virgin not by choice but
due to lack of takers throughout the
years
oh she tightened tardy you know what I'm
saying 25 and still a virgin
that's Titan tardy boo boo more I think
it's a rarity in this day and age to be
25 and a virgin and I worry it will be a
turn-off for any guy when he finds out
and that only heightens my insecurities
about it yeah I know it's definitely a
rarity to be 25 in african-american I
think in some communities I remember
reading a document the other day a lot
of young black men get killed so that is
a lot of Rarity's out there but let's
hear a little bit more but so I would
just love some insight into this pickle
of a situation from a male sexual
connoisseur such as yourself love the
podcast thanks hmm yeah and she called
that was a while back well she hit the
hotline and I want to give her a buzz
back because when a virgin calls you
call her back I mean that's schedule one
dude hey Danielle yeah hey what's up
this is Theo I'm doing great I'm doing
great how are you yeah I saw that you
reached out on the hotline and and uh
and said you wanted you know you wanted
your boy to reach out so I'm checking in
with you seeing what's going on oh wow
so you caught a little bit of it out
there huh tell me about it
okay and that's the ultimate dick
location right there okay hold on what
made you match with him I'm just gonna
start I have one little bit more
information
that's it and at this point are you
huntin were you just hunting for you
know a little bit of that you know were
you hunting for some straight up just
Street D were you hunting for some of
that strom thurmond you know what are
you looking for out there were you
actually I mean are you also at the same
time swiping thinking yeah I could meet
somebody to love or somebody to what do
you think he was just keep the
conversation going so he like showed me
that - he didn't show me much it was
just kind of like oh okay so all those
little things I was like oh look at this
look at this little you know maybe I'll
learn him in a Christmas ornament of
something I made in junior high and then
he just came up on yet now when he made
that first move did you know like like
what was the move he went for did he go
for that kiss what does he kind of just
you know what was that move okay so he
went quickly for the titty he went
quickly for it oh wow Wow and where you
read like did you go into this evening
did he know that that you were Danielle
the virgin do you know you were a virgin
I did tell him before anything happened
but it was like after the clothes were
off but before anything happened so I
was like by the way before you know
anything like she wasn't gonna stop at
that point so I was like you know hey by
the way this quick fact about me but
let's keep going so yeah that was a
little awkward on my part could have
worked out the timing a little bit
better but yeah it was fine and he just
and did he get I mean at that point was
he just right in did he come in kind of
hot how did take it take me through that
a little bit and since the first time
there's been other times and it's
definitely gotten a little bit more
intense but he was like yeah I just
wasn't sure what you could handle oh wow
and that's and this is so present-day
woman it's like you go from virgin to
this man is lackluster all in the same
sexual experience Wow
and had you like did he try anything
real frisky were you guys trying to get
real wrists gay and was he touching your
anus or anything like that or doing any
butt activity might be Kristen might be
really not Kristen could be either one
do you feel like it would have been
better used at a different time in your
life or this is your happy this is when
it worked out it's old its old it's an
old age to be in that sort of
predicament and like the next day do you
feel any different did you think any
different that's the friend that's a
hester prynne book
Scarlet woman Wow your dog was judging
you - did you really feel that look at
this little [ __ ] tosser over here huh
look at this lady over here throwing leg
around town ruining families now did you
feel a little bit more empowered like
when you saw min the next day did you
feel a little bit like yeah that's
awesome that's that's sound really good
you know yeah and did he say anything
after to like acknowledge the virginity
or the loss of virginity
did he light a candle did he put on a
special episode of television after
anything as Leslie Nielsen isn't it
yeah and he's deceased and so is your
virginity so yeah a couple of stars hit
the mat you know suave move well that's
the new Lady movement you drop your
virginity on a guy and you roll out ten
minutes I mean that's walk is in the old
days you would have stayed for the rest
of your life and started a family right
there in the room Wow so Danielle the
Virgin it's a wrap and now when it comes
to because a lot of kids are doing but
sex and all that nowadays do is that
like a next goal or something like how
does it do you start to
I mean I'd like to like get a little bit
better
just like the regular side oh yeah you
know you gotta have goals and he always
gotta be reaching for something so maybe
in the future you go I love it well best
of luck to you and I appreciate I
appreciate you calling and I don't know
if any of our did we give any good
advice it really helped your you know
think it's a big deal and then just
knowing that putting yourself out there
isn't you know as scary as it would be
because guys are just as scared I guess
in that situation as well nice and uh
and how many times have you had sex
since then and any new moves you got
under your belt there you go boy Maga
you know what I'm saying that's what I'm
talking about because those are illegal
out here by me in California yeah I mean
they're not really but I'm afraid to ask
for one it's scary
oh I Drive out to the desert even a
jerk-off out here it's very um it's a
very tight environment out here it's
tight it's tight out here yeah it's
tight in a 25 year old virgin how old
real there you go and it's a wrap so on
to the next 25 good luck getting rid of
that but V you know that's out there
next coming in for you
and I hope that your year is filled with
a lot of just real joys you know yeah
we'll check in in a couple of months and
see how it's going
alright bye-bye
and there you have it right there
Danielle the Virgin Danielle that's
we're gonna call her now cuz she lost it
you know she dropped that V off out
there to a local Caucasian and it's uh
it's nice to know that first of all that
a white guy can still get work these
days so that's nice that's a little bit
rewarding but there she is you know she
went through it and that's it you know
she took a couple suggestions to heart
maybe they may be a hitter in the heart
hit her in that vulvar that uvula or
whatever the parts are and now it's a
wrap man on to the next one man there
you heard it fellas virginity's are good
look they're dirt they're on the Block
out there so she if you out there
hunting a man get out there and get them
because these ladies are getting rid of
him we got markdown virginity's we got
used we got old new used everything must
go go go go
get out here to fat Donny's virginity's
when they be crazy if they had that a
place to dis gave sold out virginity's
and gave them out or whatever but there
you go man congratulations Danielle
welcome to the world welcome to the
world of sweet dick honey I hope you
catch a million hot rods over the years
and it could happen look people are
[ __ ] everywhere right now in Africa
and some countries people get AIDS all
the time and they still they don't even
care they [ __ ] that's how much people
want to [ __ ] that's how much people want
to have sex you know our there's our
there was a famous story about two they
had to I think they were bears and they
got they got stuck on the side of a
cliff hanging on the cliff right hanging
each by oh by a what is that thing
called it comes out of a tree that looks
for water hanging each by like a root
they were each hanging by a separate
root on the side of this cliff and they
ended up [ __ ] each other so that just
shows you the power that's out there the
power of the other that's behind a lot
of the [ __ ] that
there Roman I mean there were times I
wished that my penis was detachable and
I would just throw that [ __ ]
into the distance and hope it landed in
some wasps a you feel me just hope it
just you know there was just a crotch
just you know going deep and just Randy
Moss and my boss you feel me just
catching that that di threw you know you
just that's how I remember being so
young and it's being so funny I remember
blacking out
I remember getting so erect so much pain
so much blood running to my unit that I
would black out unconscious from just
having a hard cop you know I'm about 511
man 511 and a half and they saved you
about 511 511 and a half then you come
with that you know you got that short
bus dead that's what this girl told me
the other day she goes so you got that
short bus day that's thick and hearty
you know you got that Jared Lorenz and
you got that Chris Berman
you got that CeeLo green you got that
Archie Bunker you know that thick and
hearty you know it's more like a it
ain't like a sausage it's more like a
meatball so and that's how I do come in
I got that short bus a [ __ ] you don't
know what this thing is up to but it's
wild boo boo but anyway that's it
Danielle lost it man Danielle lost it
I'm about to lose it on you guys I'm
gonna tell you where March 15th and 16th
I'll be in Spokane actually March 15th
and 16th not being a toe toe coma Tacoma
Washington and that's outside of Seattle
and then March 17th I'll be in Spokane
April 20th and 21st I'll be in Hasbrouck
Heights New Jersey at bananas comedy
club ox and our dates got moved to July
after right after the fourth of July and
I think that's July 5th through the 6th
7th and 8th we also got some other dates
Calgary I will be in Calgary and that's
June 15th and 6th
we got some other ones coming up to him
I try to find a New York date trying to
get a Chicago in there but I just want
to let you know that those some dates
you can get tickets at Theo von comm
slash tour tou R as well you can grab a
this past weekend onward shirt at theof
on comm slash store sto ar e a
predominant mentioned that to you or not
but I'll be there at the Attic at Rock
Brothers brewing and those tickets are
available online as well I'm going to
tell you now about star flow star flow
the location for fans trying to link up
and get closer to their favorite
celebrities star flow it's a safer
ecosystem where your information won't
be sold on the black market a lot of
these but you know amps in this you get
in there and that's all the sudden your
shits on a black market you know
suddenly you got somebody showing up at
the house selling you [ __ ] you know
uh bootleg dimetapp you know or selling
you [ __ ] secondhand robitussin
but star flow it's not like that star
flow is a place for fans to link up with
their celebrities and see the latest
hottest content I mean talking about hot
content where your where your
information is safe you're not going to
be sold out it provides a hub for
consumers access your favorite talent
celebrities and exclusive content in
seconds it's available in the App Store
or its star flow STAAR FL o WM star flow
is reshaping the influencer economy by
providing an infrastructure network
enabling our ecosystem where individuals
can thrive and where everybody can
interact and participate in the creation
and consumption of value you're not
getting baited to a new place just to
have your information sold that helps
that happens a lot so you want to see
your celebs you want to see them in a
facet where you can trust the template
that you're on go to star flow comm or
check out star flow in the App Store
we had a divorced dad or soon-to-be
divorced dad messages last week as well
saying he's getting a divorce
it's been eight years
he has a daughter what does he do now he
mentioned that he was looking forward to
getting some new blow jobs or any blow
jobs and and so let's check in we had
some advice that came in for the newly
divorced dad as well here we go
hey what's up the old this was fall from
the East Bay what's up Paulie from that
East Bay and my friend got mugged one
time in Hayward I don't if you've ever
been there in Hayward homeward just
wanted a time in real quick on the
fellow's getting the horse
congratulations it sounds like you know
that's kind of what he wanted to do I
went through so I'm real similar a lot
nothing but I went through this exact
thing about eight years ago had to have
two children with my ex-wife and the
best piece of advice that I got was
understand that being the best father
you can be you're your ex-wife is gonna
benefit from that I think a lot of us
that get divorced try to be the best
that we can be but kind of lay this
gauntlet down of like you know we don't
want to we don't want to be nice or give
anything to the ex-wife cuz most of the
time you know we get divorced because
things didn't go the way you know we
thought they would wow that's really
Paul I appreciate that
that's it seems insightful you know he
doesn't seem like he's thinking about
himself as much he's just saying be the
best dad you can be and that's actually
gonna benefit your partner there let's
hear a little bit more anyhow that was
one thing just uh she's gonna benefit be
cool with that accept that make friends
with that and just be consistent my
ex-wife and I were not on good terms for
about three three and a half years a
long time she was a complete and utter
[ __ ] and you know see-you-next-tuesday
baby that's what they call them
sometimes homework you know just
consistency year after year and man
honestly now I could say she's you know
one of my better friends and we have a
great co-parenting relationship which
obviously benefits the kids greatly
which I'm sure you know this guy wants
Wow
you know this and that's some selfless
that's some selfless suggestion right
there and that's the thing
don't be thinking about you think about
the child and think about being helpful
to your ex-wife because being helper to
your ex-wife is actually in turn being
helpful to your child
now hopefully you don't get one of them
ex-wife's is just dry out there dragging
you into the mud and beating you in the
neck with that money stick you know I
remember they had this lady that lived
by me and she would go beat up her
ex-husband all the time and get his
money and steal stuff out of his place
all kind of stuff bicycle vases canned
good all kind of stuff take it right out
of his place and beat his ass cuz she
was tough you know because she was
polish she was 100% polish and they'll
[ __ ] your bra do it a buddy of mine he
was [ __ ] this Polish girl and she
beat his ass while they were having sex
and that doesn't even seem like it
should be legal but I don't know and who
and what if you come during that that's
got to be the weirdest thing what am I
talking about today oh but that's good
advice here are some good suggestions
there let's hear another one we got we
got we got one more call that came in
right here here we go hey I just wanted
to give you a call man and comment on
something that you were talking about I
thought was really interesting you're
taking two sides of the spectrum of the
marriage one that's pretty loaded both
guys in my opinion are both looking at
it the wrong way okay so he's talking
about the marriage and and the divorce
he's saying that both guys are looking
at it the wrong way
onward the common denominator between
those two guys is honestly they're both
selfish just look you know it's the only
thing that they're concerned about is I
I together with my baby's mother we just
had our second child
and I think the biggest thing that I've
been learning along the way is you got
to live in the service of other people
if you're continuing he's saying the
biggest thing along way you have to live
in the service of other people more and
to live and try to make yourself the
main focus you'll never be happy and I
think that's what they're both battling
with right now marriage is something
that you can't be selfish with and you
have to live there separate people there
you go something you can't be selfish
with he's saying you know that these
gentlemen are being selfish you know
I'll say this from a child's perspective
you know his comments make me think that
from a child say I'm a child and you
tell me you know I start finding out
the parents get married and stuff like
that I'm six or seven or whatever and I
find out you know my parents aren't
married does that make me feel a certain
way as a child it might you know my
parents don't live together that make me
feel maybe less than other kids are
different than other kids they could you
know if you're gonna ask me do you want
your parents to be married or do you
want them to live a separate from
separate and be happy as a kid I'd be
like I want them to be married so when
it you know a child in a child's world
everything it all revolves around them
and it should that's that's just the way
it is and if something's wrong then they
see it as something's wrong with them so
if something's wrong and you know their
parent the parent relationship isn't
there then they a lot of times they'll
internalize that is oh I did something
something I did something wrong that
made this be this way you know I don't
deserve to have you know a dual parent
household you know so you know it's
funny if you ask a kid a kid will tell
you exactly what they want don't want
you guys to live together now is that
realistic for the parents maybe not
probably not a lot of cases but but it's
just interesting it's interesting to
think that a child would be like no I
want you to live together that's it you
made me and you want to be on parents
and that's it so we see it differently
of courses where the parents you know
we're adults we're older but from a
kid's perspective and I don't blame them
that's not selfish of a child that's
exactly probably they should think oh
man I think about what else I want to
tell you guys it's been going on with me
what else has been going on not too much
man I got almost a day of no smoking you
know I have me a couple cigarettes after
that wedding last night and action only
had one cigarette and and it was a good
treat man it was a good treat I'm just
just a lot of happened this week so many
of those weeks that are just heavy with
emotion you know friends getting married
you know you know thinking about maybe
getting some pets or something about a
house you know a lot of just different
thoughts going through my head you know
thinking about maybe making myself a
fresh meal or something like doing some
some meals around the house you know
when I was in the French Quarter last
night and I'm trying to find a pun of
get it get into the apartment and stuff
like that and the French Quarter a great
place if you want to see somebody get
shot or some or you want to get a good
sandwich and watch somebody get cut up
or something by a burglar or whatever
you got to go to the French Quarter I
mean the French Quarter is a great place
a great place to watch - you know thick
white dudes fistfight in the street over
beads it's a great place usually like
around 2:30 kind of like a lot of young
brothers kind of with dreads and stuff
will roll through sometimes just
clipping people with knives just hatch
it in people and this is generalizations
but if you look at nola.com these things
super accurate you know it's just a
great place to get a couple of [ __ ]
you know fill your failure mouths go buy
bourbon house fill your mouth with a
good po-boy sandwich and watch a couple
people get stabbed or lose a little bit
of blood and and it's and I remember one
time I was in the French Quarter and
this man this man came up to me and he
was geeking a little bit you could see
him you know he was up on the dust he
was up on that dust and his his neck was
moving but his head and his chest
weren't and when that's going on you
know somebody you know I'm saying they
got that their soul is they got that
they hooked up on the chemicals you know
their soul is doing a little bit of they
see eating somewhere inside of their own
universe a little bit they losing it
and he said hey man you know I'll do
I'll do a back flip for you and oh my
buddy he goes hey man give me a you know
four dollars or something and my buddy's
like no ma'am and guys like all right
give me five dollars and I have to say
did it that point I laughed I loved his
approach to business
but then my buddy's like look man if you
can do a backflip I'll give you eight
dollars because my buddy had eight
dollars so the man's like all right all
right
y'all give me some room and we were
already not standing real close to this
dude because this is not a dude you
wanted to stand real close to Andhra
this dude I don't know if you ever seen
this dude this dude swaying his arms
forward back or forward backward and
then this guy try to do a backflip
obviously had never done a black a
backflip in his life in his life and
I've never seen anybody just slam the
back of their body into the [ __ ]
Street I just have never seen anything
like that like as hard as he could he
just slammed the in his entire body into
the [ __ ] Street and that was it ma'am
he was hurt he was definitely not doing
well he was not doing well I mean he
could have had who knows he could have
fractured his ribs who knows but he my
buddy gave him the eight bucks and that
was that so that's pretty beautiful you
know when you get that you know that's
the kind of a cheap show but the French
Quarter has that if you have you never
been in New Orleans you know you want a
crab dip you want a little crime that's
the place to do it we got another call
that came in right here onto the hotline
and that hotline is nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three if you're
a young man or young lady who struggling
with something and you think that other
young men and young women can offer you
suggestions if you have a comment or a
thought based on what we what we've been
talking about this week
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three as well I want
to thank our charter sponsor great block
pizza we're not finishing up here I just
want to remember to thank them they're
at 1811 Pico Boulevard and they have
bronx-born pizza and that's up in Bend
Oregon and that's brand-new also I want
to advertise this past weekend we got a
box of uh I got a box of blue t-shirts
made and these these hem efforts are
correct
they're Correctional Center blue that's
the only place you would see this color
blue is in a Correctional Center I mean
they are you know they are frankie
grande blue they're not they not there
bluh and if you hit the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and just leave it has to be 60
seconds or less
okay tell me about your weekend if it
was good or if it was bad but it has to
be the best or worst weekend you've ever
had and it has to have happened you know
you wanted to have happen it recently
we're in do this for the whole year and
once a month we're gonna put the best
one on and the worst one on and and
we're gonna send you guys some of these
Correctional Center blue this past
weekend shirts as a gift for whoever
gets them each month so you can hit the
hotline with that that number is nine
eighty five six six four nine five zero
three now if you call every week about
your shitty weekend or whatever don't do
that
don't be like that but don't be a
scavenger you know call when you got
something real also if you just a
regular person that has a regular job
you drive you know you deliver you know
newspapers like my mother does or you
you cut trees like my brother does if
you do if you a regular person you have
a regular job and you listen to this
past weekend hit the hotline sometime
and just tell me what you do and that
you listen to it tell me what you do I
just want to know who listens to this
show I'm trying to find out and I know a
lot of people out there in the dark arts
listen but I know they got others as
well let's take this right here we got a
call that came in right here here we go
hey this is Ben from Maui Hawaii
Vince that freaking that the Pied Piper
a pineapple hitting the airwaves here
from Hawaii Aloha boy more I was just
warning you I'm an MMA fighter I know
you've been commenting on a lot of MMA
fights recently with the Mike Perry deal
yeah Mike Perry and Max Payne Griffin
and that's only about the maybe fourth
or fifth fight I've ever seen and people
been asking me about that about him mmm
a fights and I'll comment on it
sometimes you know I don't want to
overstep into a territory that I don't
know much about but I am a new fan you
know I'm a little bit scared to them to
be a fan because they got a lot of
violence I don't know if you ever seen a
fight or not but it's fighting
as people fighting as people beating
each other and sometimes they know each
other and sometimes they don't and it is
viola they got some real adult violence
and they got women to that cornrow their
hair and beat each other and it's uh
it's something else man so sometimes I
can't stomach at all but I'm gonna try
to comment on some more fights here and
there when I can and so I appreciate you
checking in about that but I want to
hear what you're saying here you were
eight you you're a part-time MMA fighter
or sometimes and you're from Hawaii
let's hear more Vince and with that
masters in fight but um yeah and I've
been training for a while now it's been
about two years and I actually I tore my
ACL so I'm out for like nine months and
I'm pretty uh not feeling too good about
that I've been getting into the dark
arts but I just wanted if you had
anything that that ever said you career
backer yeah I know I know kind of comedy
has it has its ups and downs but I just
wanting if you had anything that set you
back don't worry you never thought you
you never get the end of it but you know
have I had something like that that set
my career back you know I'll tell you
this I'll tell you about two instances
that kind of just pop into my head and I
don't know if they were late a hundred
percent but they do you know they do
come to mind I when I was let me see
when I was when I just kind of just
started comedy I was at a party in the
Hollywood Hills I had a manager out here
and I think the general he might end up
being possible a homosexual man and
that's fine whatever dude you know you
know if the world's ending a a lot of
people gonna be [ __ ] each other but um
but this man was my friend and he took
me to a party and at this party was
Robert Downey jr. and Robert Downey jr.
'he's he he was not popular at all in
Los Angeles at the time he was not doing
well it's probably 15 years ago we saw
him at a pool um and I remember at the
party already making fun him he just
gotten busted for something like
picking up a prostitute or and look I'm
just guessing I don't know what he but
he got intro over something pretty bad
drugs something bad is far you know even
though Hollywood's full of [ __ ]
lecherous weirdos and that's why I'm not
watching the movie Awards tonight I
don't give a [ __ ] who wins half this
[ __ ] but I'll tell you who've been
winning it Dunkirk boy
Dunkirk a movie about men helping each
other out war times an actual real ass
movie the only movie Dunkirk not this
fake ass sugar [ __ ] that's out there
trying force politics bullet that means
nothing but come on make a movie if
you're making movies how about this I
don't know make a movie I want
entertainment that's what I want you
know why I turn on entertainment for
entertainment not to be a subtext really
preached at by some you know in some
[ __ ] fashion you know now for you to
secretly try and tell me that you think
I'm a racist or that you're smarter than
me book or that you're better than me
because you have more money I don't need
any of that [ __ ] I don't want that when
I want to watch a movie I want
entertainment and if you look around and
the move is this yeah and you want to
see you which one was the most
entertaining bump-bump
Dunkirk boy gang gang anyway what are we
talking about [ __ ] I don't even know man
no I'm listening to this call Oh Vince
MMA fighter oh so you had Robert Downey
jr. was at this party and guess what
people were making fun of memories like
all [ __ ] that guy what a loser people
were saying what a loser
and this was like the first celebrity I
had seen in Los Angeles you know someone
that you know I'm excited about anything
I'm just excited have a [ __ ] a clean
shirt on and I was up in the Hollywood
Hills and there you know buddy making
fun of him and [ __ ] now fast forward six
seven years I'm at this event for Kirk
Douglas I'm speaking at it and I thought
it was a roast I thought they said roast
we want you to roast
kirk douglas and it and and it they
actually said host we want you to host
this event about kirk douglas kirk
douglas is like ninety years old he just
had a couple strokes that were giving
him a Lifetime Achievement Award he
could barely even say the alphabet he
said you know like her and I'm out there
like I get up there and I start roasting
him making fun of him the whole place I
mean this is at Beverly it's like at a
fancy hotel everybody's like bro I am
sweating my spine is sweating like my
spine is like my spine is like I'm out
of here
my every I am drowning in my own inner
[ __ ] boil from fear just and I can't
even feel myself talking anymore it's
like I'm hiding inside of myself scared
and my face and body are telling jokes
and I'm just making fun of Michael
Douglas or Kirk Douglas
sorry Kirk Douglas and fast forward I
get offstage it's not a good scene I'll
walk backstage and I'm like Jesus Christ
that was the worst experience I mean
Sally Field is there about his air and
Robert Downey jr. standing backstage and
he you know and now he's he's he's Iron
Man and he's the most popular guy in the
room and I was like man that was really
tough and he goes hey man you know what
he said in ten years nobody will
remember this and I looked at him I said
we you yeah say you would know and I
respected you know I've told this story
before but it just meant it's like you
know yeah you take it and but if he to
ask me that day if right now do I think
I'd be you know doing well at comedy and
working hard and coming up there and
battling through these ranks even though
they don't want to give it to me they
don't want to give it to some poor white
kid because that goes against everything
they ever thought out here know if
you're poor and white you'd is supposed
to be racist you're just supposed to be
ignorant you're just supposed to be
untraveled you're just supposed to nah
you know no dreams are only for you know
people of you got to have some skin tone
you it's got to fit the commercial [ __ ]
them [ __ ] them bro that's what I'm
saying dude is I'm in this I'm in this
thing and I didn't any word to any of
you to ask me when I walked back behind
that stage I'd have been ah you know and
I was looking at Robert Downey jr. no
man I felt horrible I felt like I would
never work again in this town I went
back home ate a bunch of pills and
watched uh the first season a house of
cards
I think or I could have watched um that
show house I don't remember which one it
was dude I ate a lot of pills bro but I
was devastated I thought about leaving
town because I just had a room a 700
people in Hollywood they're free I mean
this thing was huge huge I had no idea
was gonna be like this
and Here I am telling that you know but
here but now but that's not the story
today now I'm taking these meetings and
these people coming at me with ideas and
they come and see what daddy's doing so
what I'm saying is you know you're in a
tough spot now don't think that the
future can't be different you could
change it may harm
perseverance open your eyes move your
legs man dude if you're an MMA fighter I
know you have you do you have that
physical side already mapped in it's
mapped into your system I bet so you
just keep that keep the physical side
going and you'll be fine man I promise
you you I bet you if you don't give up
on that MMA in that jujitsu even if you
don't do it professionally to keep
fighting don't give up on it as a source
in your life a lot of people reached out
to me recently said man you should get
into this [ __ ] because it helps you
learn patience it helps you learn
practicality and I watch these men and
they're gladiators they are warriors and
I used to I used to not like them
fighting I used to not like that you
know I grew up in a violent area with no
protection and I felt scared you know
when I saw this
reminding me some of that I guess you
know and it made me feel scared but so
there's a couple of instances in there
that can relate to what you're talking
about and hear what they are I didn't
give up and I'm still doing this [ __ ]
and I'm stumped you know I'm not gonna
give up and Robert Downey jr. when I saw
him he had been I mean I mean at this
people were making fun of him he was at
a shitty party if I was there it wasn't
a good party jack and then fast forward
seven years and he's [ __ ] Iron Man
okay a man that is based off of one of
the periodic elements so you just hold
the line man stay the line and that's
what's going on man we're here in the
new studio it's been good it's been fun
and it's been good fun and I look I'm
excited and I'm gonna be here
we'll be here this week things things
are gonna start to happen thank you
everybody thank you for calling in Thank
You Stevie starlight for kicking us off
strong we got this you know we you know
what I'll tell you this I didn't come
this far to stay where I am I didn't and
if you need something to get in your
heart and beat and be a word or two and
you take a little bit of that and I'm
not preaching at you man I'm working
with you man
if you struggling you in a moment of
struggle you not only you're not alone
man you are not alone because I'll tell
you who you got you have yourself you
have yourself man and you did not come
this far to stay where you're at
be good to yourself man you probably
deserve it thank you to everyone for the
support I'm in a new studio today if you
asked me a year ago if I thought I could
be here I don't know
no I don't know but here I am and here
you are we're here we did it man we made
it we made this boy fighter in the kid
that's what they get you don't give me a
belt you don't give me AK mug
these [ __ ] say guess it a year
and then give me a dang um a little uh
uh hats or uh you know uh scarf or
anything a shirt pen and they saying
guess it a year not a stick or nothing
and they cheat you know and then you
know they cheap skating because Brendan
Schaub over there wearing $70 socks you
know Bryan Callen over there doing tests
100 in deca and others probably other
roids from the 1980s and a singing out
the cash to get daddy a little belt I
don't believe it at you guys hit the
hotline if you need me man
and it's 95 six six four nine five zero
three Danielle thank you so much for
calling in thank you to Gio and those
who responded to Gio thank you to the
new divorced dad and those who responded
to him and somebody is I'm happy to be
here
and let's take it out with my boy Stevie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
tell him CV
[Music]
[Applause]
time slips away
[Music]
so Tony
turn the Stevie starlight
Wow
chances come along Valentine